c'est parti draft sur les portland trail
blazers ce pour ça j'ai comme invité un
membre de buzzer france romain c'est le
roumain salut à tous le monde salue la
weser stadion merci envergure pour pour
l'invitation
ouais et un petit merci aussi adrien
dont on suit le bac est aujourd'hui
hockey et baboo jouera d'ailleurs
puisque sans doute qui doit être en
train de regarder pour tout cas y
regarder on en arrive t
on à manu qui avec manu qui fera qui
détaillera les profils dont on va parler
avec eux son oeil expert et sa langue
fourchue celle survenue savoir comment
ça vaille et coûte très bien et enfin
celui qui affole tender night limite ça
nous monsieur allen guillou comment ça
va aller ça va être très saine intro
très très très très intéressant très
éclectique j'ai voulu faire on va
commencer direct réplication on va dire
bravo qui va évidemment vu qu'ils seront
là ils sont déjà tout ça ils ont attendu
parce qu'on a été un petit peu en retard
romain a eu des problèmes de transport
n'a attendu que tout se goupille donc
encore désolé pour le retard évidemment
on va y aller tout de suite maintenant
romain pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi ou
de très loin la saison 2 de portland
qu'est ce qui s'est passé comment on
explique un petit peu près ce naufrage
ce serait un petit peu exagéré mais
cette contre performance
il ya eu plein plein d'événements tout
au long de la saison je dirais que le
principal événement c'est la blessure de
l'île heard
qui a tout de suite handicapés
handicapé l'équipe du quasiment tous les
domaines et petit à petit en fait
il ya eu de plus en plus de deux
déconvenues un effectif pas forcément
très bien construit très inégale
toujours des gros problèmes en défense
des changements dans le front office qui
ont amené
des gros bouleversements en cours de
saison notamment avec la nomination du
rck ronin en tant que general manager
qui a fait un gros ménage dans
l'effectif
avec le départ de mc collum de line
dance de rock de robert green town
de norman powell et ça s'est soldé du
coup à la fois par an gros l'île heard
qui met fin à sa saison et du coup le
manque le mois de parking qui est
activée après la très belle
après dans dans ces pays si et quand
même une lueur d'espoir j'ai envie de
dire avec rod fanni siemens qui a joué à
un niveau sur les derniers mois qu'elle
n'attendait pas forcément
voilà tout à fait nous on l'avait vu un
peu éclore en tant que que potash
twitter on va dire beaucoup dans le tir
dans le tir assez peu à la création quoi
et effectivement le départ de mâts colom
et la blessure de lille à lui ont permis
d'avoir pas mal de responsabilités
et effectivement il s'est révélé il
s'est révélé donc oui elle lui a dit
sport
alors est-ce que tu as suivi un peu les
mésaventures de leur profil de l'orégon
bien sûr une équipe qui tant que ça
m'intéresse toujours
exactement
donc ouais bah je pense que romain et
lacq odyssée montée n'est pas le but je
pense pas le but je pense tout chauncey
billups d'arrivée des doses un gymnase
une reconstruction je pense qu'il
voulait gagner que second plat mais à
des blessures
tu as une fin de saison plus plus tôt
que prévu entre guillemets donc tu tu
change de cap quand jusqu'au dernier
moment mais je te met dans la position
pour peut-être te relancer rapidement tu
des graisses surtout en terme de salaire
je pense que ça et c'est le plus
important pourquoi payer autant de
salaire si tu peux pas vraiment à vous
jouer quelque chose donc ça qu'il ya eu
du trade avec les clippers qui en plus a
ramené qui en john sonne peut-être
qu'ils aient mettions en avant la draft
donc ça peut ça peut leur faire un
prospect qui sera organisée avec un
prospect et ensuite le traite de mc
collum ou peut-être qu'ils apprécient
aussi le chart qui peut l'être une pièce
du futur des bladers donc tu gagnes avec
des unes des pièces que tu peux ajouter
je pense que simons le collectif était
resté au de développement en tant que
porteur de balle quand il n'était plus
là ça a été fait il est moyennement
hyper impressionné sur le mode choisi de
lui sans l'île heard s'ajouter à ce
résultat résulte est souvent été défaite
mais bon c'était parce qu'à côté c'était
pas incroyable
et puis tu te places avec un pic dans le
top 10 dans une robe ce n'est pas
incroyable mais qui est plutôt homogène
plus donc je trouve que c'est celle en
fait c'est vraiment le scénario le moins
pire qu'ils auraient pu faire sans leur
avait dit en décembre pour c'est
vraiment la galère
oui j'avoue m'être l'effectif qui est
actuel pour portland sachant que
donc voyez avoir ce pic sept après il ya
deux autres piques qui sont un peu plus
lointain si ces 57 si je dis pas de
bêtises
et que portland la cale de l'argent à
dépenser c'était donc ça c'est entre
guillemets la bonne nouvelle aux mains
pour toi dans tout ce qu'il y a là
comment tu vois un peu à l'intersaison
un sur deux c'est de chez sûr je dirais
qu'il est la référence et
donc envers nick et qu'il signerait
le reste avec moi ça c'est compliqué
parce que même des joueurs que je pense
que quand la diane on estime comme art
ou comme la sierra little étant donné
que officiellement le la position de la
franchise c'est de reconstruire très
rapidement elle est là et de l'envahir
fit et sa table
je serais pas étonné que même des
joueurs qu'on apprécie ce soit
disponible pour faire pour faire des
échanges et après il ya toute une petite
bête et de joueurs
qui à johnson did i know that a
brand winslow ça pour le coup je pense
que
c'est une variable d'ajustement
et après moi je dirais qu'il ya aussi à
deux joueurs qu'on a vu un peu à la fin
moment de du temps que c'est c'est
traîne danois de ford et
j'ai brandon williams qui a été si tous
les deux ont été signés en fête a été
signé en tant que que tué et l'autre a
été signé
et
je pense que ces deux joueurs ont marqué
des points pendant le temps qui est que
pour le coup ils ont des chances d'être
d'être là la démo début de saison
prochain
à l'année manu j'ai mis entre guillemets
le lion corps qui a portland tient
johnson qu'ils ont récupérés via un
trade
qui vient de texas et
brasilia nasirli tell
deals à la ouate ford tout ça ça a moins
de 23 ans est ce qu'il ya moyen de ce
que c'est potentiellement des rôles
players solide autour de deux thèmes
l'île heard a
pas l'année prochaine voilà les projets
témoignent
à little peut-être farrelly talent c'est
devenu un fait on dit plutôt plutôt
solide c'est pas le joueur que tout le
monde présentait comme antique et un
risque ou non pas trop mais c'est pas
pour autant que c'est pas un bon genre
don king je pense que c'est un bon jeune
dort ici moi j'avais l'apprécié beaucoup
et drame de portland même quand il était
vraiment très bon il hydrate et toujours
sur une potentielle et ça ça paye entre
guillemets parce que simons et little
ces deux jours qui était très jeune
normande est drafté avec peu
d'expérience mais zidane c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces deux jours je pense
vraiment compté dans l'ossature de
l'équipe mais je pense que comme l'a dit
romain festival est compétitif l'an
prochain qui vont utiliser des assets et
des contrats expirants donc le contrat
expirant terrible et cela notamment je
pense pour pour bouger aller chercher un
jour si c'est ce qui va le faire ils ont
les armes pour le faire
est-ce que
alors on a parlé donc de la saison
décevante
comment
comment est-ce que la blessure de l'île
heard explique tout quand même ou pas
pour moi non parce que
[Musique]
c'est longtemps j'ai à dire voiler la
face du côté de portland mais en fait
l'effectif était comme j'ai dit les
bulles mal construit c'est à dire trop
petit
qui ont posé sur trop de guar
trop attirés
par
dire le 3 points et l pull-ups pas assez
de diversité dans l'effectif que ce soit
en termes de profil ou même de produits
physiques ou prou profil de jeu quoi
donc pour moi c'est pas qu'une attaque
que sur la blessure de mineurs je pense
que ça a été un déclencheur et que en
gros une autre attaque qui cachait notre
défense
très mauvaise défense en fait tout d'un
coup notre attaquant cette apc et et a
révélé en fait tous les problèmes dire
effectivement
on va parler du jeu comme tu as dis donc
nouveau nouvel entraîneur nouveau gm en
cours de saison
menés 1-2 chauncey billups qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire de lui en tant que coach
ce qu il ya des leçons en tirez en fait
l'essai de soin d'aborder les matches
soit 2 il faut mettre en place
j'ai pas un printemps sur la tacc on n'a
pas vu énormément de la différence ça
reste une équipe qui joue énormément de
pick and roll beaucoup d'isolation
et ensuite va chercher des trois ponts
vers d'un corner ou à la limite tu joues
avec marqué dessus
sur le pick and roll en défense il a
essayé de nouvelles choses avant on
était vraiment une équipe très
conservatrice qui faisait beaucoup de
drops
et on a tenté pas mal de choses du show
du beaucoup de blitz
a pas vraiment eu de résultats nouveau
mais il ya eu des nouvelles choses en
défense en tout cas sur la couverture du
pick and roll donc je pense billups de
plus agressives en défense mais sinon ça
se calme un tournoi ces jeunes je sais
pas si on peut dire qu'il a déjà trouvé
sa sa patte
à la même question chauncey billups en
année est ce qu'il ya une marque
chauncey billups du bon en attaque déjà
moi ce que j'ai vu sur les stades
avancés en tout cas c'est que c'était
une des équipes qui prouve qu'ils
utilisent et le plus de offscreen ouais
je pense qu'il risque d'être assez assez
précis tu es un peu dans la moyenne dont
tout mais c'est vraiment on sait qui
ressortait en fait je pense qu'à
plusieurs saisons dans l'une en fait
la saison avec l'état 3 manta la saison
et le nullard de la saison où c'est
simone le porteur de balle est à la
saison
tankink quoi à la fin de l'année donc
difficile pour moi de faire c'est de
trouver des grands procès mais quand je
les ai vus c'est plutôt de défensivement
je trouve comme l'environnement où il a
essayé des choses qu'on fait pendant
quatre cinq ans ce qui se passe à
portland c'est qu'on essaie juste de
mettre plus de points que l'adversaire
pour essayer de deux de gagner même
temps c'était un peu ça se pourrait se
comprendre quand avec le personnel qui
était utilisée est un bac courte
extrêmement fort offensivement mais qui
était limité physiquement et
défensivement donc tu mets des soldes à
côté d'eux s'ils peuvent à tous les
soldats qu'on a eu les amis nous les
arcs laisse les mêmes les covington
épousa ensuite ils ont essayé l'an
dernier la dernière année de stock de
jouets très petit avec powell en 3 et de
vraiment tous basés sur la taxe n'a pas
trop marché donc là ils se sont dit je
pense on va prendre quelqu'un qui va
être plus dans les schémas plutôt que
dans les kivus et de même avec un
personnel un peu défiant de t2 sauf
qu'il a jamais vraiment il son équipe au
complet donc pas vraiment le juger en
fait sur ça j'attends vraiment l année
prochaine et plus la troisième année
pour voir déjà s'il rechigne rqic ou pas
parce que c'est la base de tout angle
dépenses exercice s'il est là et ce
n'est pas tu peux faire plus de 2 tu
peut switcher s'il est pas là tu peux
faire beaucoup d'europe s'il est là
j'attends plus de voir quels sont les
prochains intérieur qui va qui va avoir
sous la main pour peut-être avec le
pixel peut être à la flotte génocide
est ce que c'est un motif d'inquiétude
l'intérieur du futur romain
ou pas vous pensez que nous recherchons
est parti pour rester
moi j'ai l'impression qu'un un catch est
parti pour rester parce que
pour un joueur qui est censé être en fin
de contrat du coup jouer son prochain
contrat je trouve qu'ils ont proposé
assez tôt donc
ça me semble aller vers la sphère un
contrat et vers un accord contre après
les rumeurs en ce moment ils vont contre
un iphone
donc c'est compliqué de dire pour
l'instant qui sera l'intérieur
principale apporte prochaine mais
j'irai quand même pour l'instant
et on va parler un petit peu à la légère
venir vers toi côté défensif est ce
qu'on a vu justement un vrai changement
d'identité comme l'avait souligné romain
sur le côté un peu abandonné le drop
pas dans le monde
elle a parlé de moi je trouve quoi ils
ont été beaucoup d'être beaucoup plus
agressif quand je voyais les voiles et
surtout ce qu'elle devienne de passe ce
que faisait un peu même fille cependant
aussi et c'est en fait de créer beaucoup
d'interceptions beaucoup de contes pour
ensuite se créent des paniers faciles je
trouve que quand je regarde un peu
porter un des mines esquissé ce qu'ils
essayaient de faire après
personnellement c'est pas l'équipe que
j'ai regardé le plus sur la fin de
l'année avait tous les grecs branza même
si ce sera les quelques mois je pouvoir
qui remet en somme puisque on était tous
très bonne note hugh johnson envergure
donc c'était un gars que je le regardais
mais je trouvais que il était quand même
beaucoup plus agressif c'était plus une
défense qui était vous agresser sur la
lune de passe qui tentait plus de plus
d'être dans les stoks donc à
l'interception bloc plutôt que les
années précédentes après ce que c'est
une marque de fabrique ou est-ce que
c'est simplement des parce qu'ils ont
joué et qui perdez pas mal de ballons à
certains moments je sais pas le choix ça
c'est ce vide ça se lira plus sur la
prochaine année pendant deux ans et tout
ça dans notre identité défensive qui va
mettre en place me l'a dit le ski est en
fait ce que montre après un peu les
listes à que j'ai ici de mettre en
valeur la j'ai affiché c'est justement
ce côté là c'est le côté son état
étonnamment bon tri mais sur les
interceptions
la huitième équipe de la vie alors
qu'ils trouvent ans après 25 à chaque
fois dans les casinos dans les autres
catégories
qu'elles soient des français barretines
ou de protection de serre peut aussi
des points encaissés sur tron over parce
qu'ils perdent énormément de ballons
l'hérault ou défensif aussi sur lesquels
ils sont pas très bon ça soigne et ça
revient à ce que romain tu disais sur le
manque de taille dont notamment même si
le rebond ce n'est évidemment pas que ça
mais quand même ça peut jouer un peu
on voit passer maintenant à ce qui nous
intéresse le plus au regard dur il ya x
est du coup qu'est-ce qu'on en fait de
sa
race est la question
qu tels que je suis tu as entendu tu as
lu des chevaux des dernières rumeurs si
tu suis un peu je parlais les journaux
locaux via l'autoroute
juste après la loterie
il y avait un petit peu de déception
quand même d'être tombé en cette même si
c'est la place logique selon les pro ben
tout 47 près mais on a vu lui l'art
notamment qu'elle avait été repris qui
représentait les blazers saloperies pas
être hyper content du pic cède et à ce
moment là
c'était
tout de suite d'importantes va échanger
sont peggy donc toujours dans cette idée
de quitter la table avec damas les
larves et changer le pid contre un
joueur avec plus d'expérience capable
d'apporter tout de suite
je dirais que depuis quelque temps
et je pense que c'est dû au fait que ben
yahia le combat ne puis après des work
out sur certains joueurs je pense que
c'est plus mitigé maintenant c'est
difficile d'avoir une vraie indication
est aussi dès
le recrutement de mike schmidt alors il
n'est pas censé s'occuper de la tarte
pour les heures ce 17e et cette
intersaison mais ça a mis un peu de flou
et je pense que l'autre point qui est
aussi mis un peu de flou c'est que
joe croone il en fait avant d'être j'ai
mis la clé pas mal de postes au niveau
au sein de l'organisation des briseurs
c'est notamment elle était scout est
donc tout ça fait que
c'est assez
il n'y a pas vraiment de direction qui
est donnée pour l'instant même si même
si je dirais que les rumeurs de
transfert c'est un système répond pour
l'instant on est peut-être encore un peu
tôt pour savoir vraiment quelles
indications qu'elle me route va prendre
maintenant
menu et robin je vais me tourner vers
groupe qu'est ce que ça vaut peaks est
surtout dans cette draft en termes de
joueurs vous parlait il ya eu un moment
la rumeur un peu insistante avec chiara
une grande épisode il posta vous ce
genre de joueurs
dans sept tués
money peut-être
c'est difficile quand c'est difficile
c'est une draft à cinq joueurs quatre
cinq joueurs seulement sont considère
shannon a donc finalement le pix à
partir du 5 s'il ya rarement des pics à
l'eau parce que ça va être des joueurs
moi je considère en fait d'avoir plus ou
moins de réfrigérant il faut pas faire
ça mais de plus ou moins drafté au
talent mais aussi au fit alors qu'est ce
que marc schalk est ce qu ont besoin les
blesssures en fait
là elle vous entende parler plus ou
moins de l'intérieur donc là l'intérieur
s'il y en a un le premier le meilleur
sera parti
donc le deuxième sera diane dufresne
havrais est ce que c'est ce dont vous
avez besoin sans que vous allez plus à
l'est sur de l'ailier c'est assez
compliqué donc un pays à plusieurs
pouvoirs quand même et plusieurs cibles
a war donc c'est dur n 6 luigi griffin
johnny davis
on peut avoir tyson daniels qui est plus
sûr meneur arrière
lui qui gagnent murray on voit très très
haut sur surtout climat que aux états
unis mais moi personnellement je suis
pas
comme à l'autre hippiques
il ya plein de choses donc c'est selon
ça va être des joueurs pour moi la
partir de 5,7 ça va être des gens
rotation plus plus des genres qu'ils
vont être capables d'avoir un vrai rôle
dans la deuxième partie de saison
pouvoir l'année prochaine ou là vraiment
on va pouvoir compter sur
moi je suis assez d'accord moi c'est une
draft soit deux joueurs soient à cinq
joueurs ça dépend comment on la voit
enfin trois joueurs scène grâce à deux
ou à 5 pourtant des ans est
oui si tu veux gagner maintenant dès
l'an prochain comme l'a du roman est la
nouvelle la prochaine bonne équipe de
damon hill hard un vétéran qui tirait
chercher contre ceux de pixels et un
package et aidera sans doute plus par
contre
tu peux quand même trouvé un joueur qui
peut être un solide titulaire pendant
deux contrats une vieille et c'est pas
c'est pas ce n'est pas rien souvent
parce que on tourne vers des all stars
dans le top 10 d'une rave c'est pas ça
la vérité devra donc si tu arrives à
trouver un joueur qu elle a pendant 7 8
ans et qui petit sourire qui est un
souhait qui tuèrent nba je pense que
c'est aussi très bien donc je pense
qu'ils peuvent vraiment trouver ça après
si tu fais le choix de tout le monde
parle d'un trait de gira migrantes ou
d'un trade contre autres je pense que
j'ai ramé grand moun an prochain sera un
meilleur joueur que le pic sept oui mais
jeremy grand il faudra lui proposer une
extension et en plus j'ai un migrantes
et froid des aspirations personnelles
qui sont pas avec celle que que les que
les équipes veulent donc je pense quand
même que je porte et je resterai
sûrement en tête et je rapporterai mais
les deux sont allés de son possible
et je me permets une
graphique il ya quelques années
selon selon les pics il détermine le
rôle donc c'est tout un pourcentage est
tout un calcul et de et le pic 1 à 15 80
% du 38 % du temps donc c'est la plus
haute valeur sur les entre all star
start-up backup 5dans n'a pas joué à une
bille 38% céder la cup donc c'est pour
déterminer un peu ce qu'on peut avoir
sur sur cette partie d'un acheteur
c'est pour dire aussi à quel point c'est
un certain après il ya une solution
c'est qu'il ya aussi peut-être des
équipes mois peut-être monter à limites
est-ce que
soit c'est charlotte qui a le trait et
15 ce que ça vaut un pic cette
voie d'une solution aussi pour claudette
ont des joueurs qu'on estime avoir un
peu plus tard et qu'ils sont plus entre
dit je pense à des profils un petit peu
différent je retiens la b j de ce jour
de voir tu peux faire ça et ça peut être
positif ça peut être négative je pense
que je crois que c'est sacramento qui
regrettent tous les jours d'avoir
échangé le disque entre le 15 et le 20
parce que le dit c'est devenu la voix de
mutuelles de mémoire alors 2017 après
tout ça peut aussi bien fonctionné quand
comme craon chicago
comme contender d'ailleurs des deux
raretés avait échangé sont plus de 13
pour le pixi 16 et 19 qui était devenue
guerrière les seniors kitsch contre le
mc dermott
apprécié que lapointe c'est vraiment de
la chance mais
sept ans vrai qu'en terre dans le top 8
il a quand même une chance d'avoir un
starter on est dans ces instants plus et
ensuite c'est pas pareil que des tentes
tout ce que n'étant 15 donc il est quand
même prend une valeur différente dans ce
danseur dans ce pic l'a donc
autres vous pourrez vraiment une belle
offre pour descendre jusqu'au bout alors
faudrait un jeune un jeune d'un jeune
talent donc je pense que la presse est
possible
maintenant
romain je suis trop long c'est par
rapport justement on l'a évoqué un petit
peu en filigrane c'est le mouvement qui
a eu en interne se retrouvent depuis
comme un an et beaucoup de moutons
est ce que pour toi c'est plutôt
inquiétant ou rassurant
ben
jusqu'au va peut-être arriver après
dernières rumeurs concernant
propriétaire je dirais que jusqu'à
maintenant c'était inquiétant
parce que même si j'étais pas très fun
deny bärtschi
ce qu'on voyait c'était plutôt une
franchise
qui se dira qui s'effritaient petit à
petit
qui a changé énormément de choses au fil
des années et sans grands résultats
derrière
maintenant
ces changements ils sont peut-être aussi
annonciateur de quelque chose d'autre
c'est à dire que
il ya peut-être un ménage qui est fait
parce que en gros on sait depuis
longtemps comme suit depuis longtemps
depuis la mort en fait du propriétaire
paul allen sa soeur qui a en gros qui a
repris la direction du business de son
frère
on sait qu'elle est très peu intéressés
par les blenders d'ailleurs elle a fait
très peu de déclarations quasiment
jamais parlé publiquement des bagels
et du coup en fait on ressentait seconde
d'investissement en fait du propriétaire
dans la franchise mais avec les
dernières rumeurs qui sont sortis
concernant une future prise on peut
maintenant imaginez que tous ces
changements sont faits pour
ouais ça nettoyer en gros la franchise
de fond en comble et repartir sur des
bases
parler de nello chi g mais on travaille
sur la draft depuis 2012 et l'arrivée en
2012 on sait tous les jours qu'il a pris
il n'a pas hésité non plus à faire faire
remonter des traits de kita a lâché
et c'était surtout donc il ya eu quand
même hamlin draft des draps s'ouvre
quand même plutôt plutôt réussi
qu'on arrive à avoir l'idée que l'homme
a régalé ce qui était un beau projet
sera sur le papier quand même walkman
2017 c'est pas gagné en fait galles ils
ont récupéré une ou deux années plus
tard c'est à collins en dise
oui parce que c'est en fait c'est bien
le pic 20 et chez un autre pic en
échange pour orienter en disent d'accord
ok j'étais alors tu fais bien de
corriger
est-ce que donc joke ronin temps à
parler un petit peu c'est un peu lui il
est là depuis très longtemps aussi il
était là à côté est ce que pour toi et
pour les fans des blazers sont en france
c'est l'homme de la situation et ce
qu'il a les épaules
compliqué de se prononcer pour l'instant
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il n'a pas peur
de faire des gros changements on l'a vu
avec les retraites qu'il a effectuée
je pense qu enfin c'est encore difficile
de juger ses traits parce que je pense
qu'une partie des répercussions de ces
trade se verra ben alors que cette free
agency voire plus tard
ce qu'on peut dire quand même c'est
qu'on trouve de l'autre côté qu' il n'a
peut-être pas assez récupéré assez de
pique je dirais notamment notamment avec
le pig protégés de new orleans qui n'a
finalement pas eu
mais
ce qui ressort aussi un petit peu dans
la presse à portland c'est qu'ils
n'avaient pas non plus un énorme
engouement sur les sur les joueurs qui
ont été changés donc je sais pas où est
le juste milieu où est la réalité
donc je dirais que pour l'instant pour
kronis est mitigé mais qu'il faut aussi
lui laisser du temps parce que j'imagine
qu'il a aussi un plan en tête
donc cette idée de se créer beaucoup de
flexibilité de récupérer les assets
on va voir ce qu'il va en faire en fait
c'est toute la question qui va jouer
finalement cet été
manu ça va être ton moment parce qu'on
va commencer à parler des prospects on a
sélectionné cinq prospects pour portland
et après il dit pas non plus à dire ce
que toi tu en penses est-ce que déjà
avant de passer la main manu pour la
présentation du premier prospects est ce
qu'il ya un nom qui revient souvent
parmi les fans des baiseurs parce que la
semaine dernière on était avec orlando
il n'avait d'yeux et d'oreilles que pour
thiêt et si on avait eu le malheur de
prononcer un autre nom limitons on se
faisait rossé est ce que c'est le cas
pour portland qui a joué pour les fans
de portland qui ont jeté leur dévolu sur
quelqu'un non je dirais que c'est assez
cette savary pour l'instant
je pense que
il ya une partie qui est plutôt calme et
plutôt bien et qu'ils gagneraient parce
que il fit très très bien je pense dans
l'effectif des blenders
la très récemment il ya eu un workout de
challenger n est
le phénomène en fait et c'est alléchant
et après je dirais que globalement il
n'y a pas de
dire de joueurs
repoussoir je sais pas comment dire mais
quelqu'un qui est vraiment
on se dit que en fait c'est une draft
qui qui nous va plutôt bien je dirais
parce que il ya beaucoup de soin d
intérieur soit des swing man est assez
grand on va dire qu'ils peuvent jouer
d'autres plutôt 3 et à part le poste de
meneur qui chez nous et comblé je dirais
que le reste
du tout que plus ou moins vite et donc
il n'y a pas de joueurs qui
il ya une croix dessus et qui provoque
un rejet ouais on va commencer on a
choisi complètement aléatoirement les
destinations les a choisis selon l'
orange qu'on a sur envergure sur la vie
de bord des lacs consensus le consensus
big board pourquoi commencer par didier
griffin que alan je sais aime beaucoup
manu key de griffin pour ceux qui n'ont
rien suivi de la saison une cible dit
griffin c'est un arrière-ailier de
tomates 0 1 avec une envergure de 2 13
donc la particularité d'être g grichting
c'est qu'il a été blessé à sa sortie du
lycée sur son cursus lucien mais il a
été beaucoup touchée au niveau des
genoux et de genoux ont été touchés donc
ce qu'il a il était considéré que le
meilleur glisseur nca sa classe a à
l'époque avant blessures les blessures
sont arrivés donc c'est un joueur ultra
explosifs qu'elle est vraiment qu
attaquer le cercle vraiment avec
facilité déconcertante donc ses
blessures l'ont fait perdre justement
cette puissance et de ce ce plus qui
l'avait et du coup on demande avec ce
joueur est ce qu'il va un jour retrouver
un tout petit peu de ce qui se faisait
de sa puissance et sa classe entre
guillemets du joueur pourquoi on adorait
ce joueur donc là c'est vraiment la
construction primaire avec lui c'est
quoi le rapport médical va être ultra en
portant sur sur lui donc c'est un joueur
qui a commencé doucement haddouk du coup
par rapport à sa cb sur eto'o fils but
des matchs commencent à apprendre des
minutes à prendre dix minutes et
finalement il a start et la moitié de la
saison là de la deuxième partie de
saison il était star incontestable et il
est quasiment devenu le leader offensif
de douche avec paolo gontero
c'est un genre cas vraiment comme disait
particularité c'est qu'il est explosif
puissant un peu recréer on peut refaire
un jeu et il a vraiment être
impressionnant à 3 points notamment où
il était capable de shooter dans toutes
les positions notamment au catch and
shoot mais qui là où il était sur une
quatre tirs à trois points tentés par
match cette saison
une réussite globale de 45 % c'est très
très très très correct voire très bien
et c'est un joueur qui a été aussi quand
même capable de continuer à jouer comme
diouf c'est à l'école au lycée c'est
d'attaquer le cercle il a été très bon
sur notamment sur les coupes vers le
cercle ou des fois il est il arrivé à
bien mal son défenseur et comme le jeu
du doudouk c'est que nous poser vraiment
de tout le monde pouvait plus ou moins
bien passé la balle il y avait quand
même une belle osmose là dessus il a
réussi à capitaliser là-dessus et il a
vraiment bien attaquer le cercle en
prenant à défaut ses défenseurs / / /
défunte ce genre de choses
voici plus à l'est actuellement c'est
plus un scoreur de deux niveaux à
l'intérieur et à trois points à voir
comment il va développer le reste
comment le rapport médical ce sera vous
avez aussi c'est ça va être ça la clé
avec une messin un joueur avant ses
blessures bon on considérait top3 draft
sans sourciller
alors est ce que c'est le flic
bizarrement peut-être le plus sûr qu'il
est disponible pour portland
est ce qu'on imagine bien le fit avec
lille est rare d'avoir des fans et
siemens
oui après un mois portland s'est pas
trop envie de leur vendre un joueur avec
les blessures ou d'une grappe
qu'un pas on connaît tous on connaît le
passé donc on va dire qu'on appelle si
vous avez pas les références grego de
houston où sam bowie mais ça c'est bien
plus longtemps
en fait je pense
ses membres ses marrons oui parce que
c'est le plus faible parce que on sait
ce qui faire une bille et demain comme
l'a dit manu c'est pas ça c'était mon
genre numéro un il ya un an et demi
parce que je pense à lui je pensais que
c'était un joueur qui allait devenir un
ailier dominant capable de scorer trois
niveaux être créées est en fait il a
changé son jeu à cause des blessures est
devenu un incroyable tu ndi cette année
est du côté du coût des formes prendre
des tirs à trois points qu'à jean shoot
très bon dans les corners lotir et en
mouvement avec aussi le potentiel
d'emplois donc ça oui et ça c'est un
serra partout à une vie meilleure qui
fait de maître défend mais des trois
points peut vivre sans le ballon tout le
monde en a besoin donc ça sur sa wii je
te dirais que la voir en cet an plus en
étant un des joueurs les plus jeunes de
la draft c'est super intéressant par
contre
sur le dossier médical
c'est super compliqué parce qu'il ya les
genoux il ya le pied aussi comme on a
commencé manu donc ce qui fait qu'il a
perdu et en vivacité en explosivité
qu'il est devenu plus lourd moins
verticale et donc pour qu'il retrouve
vraiment son explosivité d'avant j'ai
quelques doutes donc peut-être qu'en
fait il a moins de potentiel que tout le
monde veut le dire c'est un genre plus
sûr il est devenu plus sûr parce qu'il
leur est demandé dans un ou deux
domaines de son jeu qui font qu'il a il
a enclenché la carrière nba par contre
il a peut-être plus est ce potentiel
qu'il avait lavé avant c'est normal y en
a tous les ans et je reconnais cette
forme potentiel il ya une blessure qui
arrive et je la fuis donc voilà
il est question tout en partie répondu
alain défensivement ça donne quoi
c'est le gros point rouge et où tout via
un peu passé à côté c'est pourtant c'est
l'une de ses qualités aussi ça en est
incroyable défenseur qui peut défendre
sur plusieurs positions notamment les
sur les trois pays sont extérieures
meneur arrière ailier
ou la latéralité quand même assez
correcte malgré les problèmes de
blessures par le passé c'est vraiment je
pense qu'un terme c'est un gars qui va
pouvoir défendre sur casino monde sur
des petites séquences
c'est vraiment un avec son attaque du
cercle c'est vraiment le point positif
c'est rarement sa défense c'est vraiment
le le truc qui va pouvoir lui faire
gagner des minutes instantanément
moi il ya une question que je pose
souvent un truc qui m'intéresse
particulièrement aux liens avec mon
métier
psychologiquement c'est quel genre de
garçon sur un terrain
cédé plus de même cette année avant
parce qu'avant infernale c'était la
halle face à tours est toutefois
dans son lycée à new york ses locks et
un fils de coach donc les fils du coach
adren griffin qui est l'ancien joueur
des wolves et l'assistant à toronto
d'ailleurs c'est avec les rapporte qu'il
a pressé toute sa rééducation
de il n'a pas passé que son lycée il a
passé avec le staff un staff qui connaît
un peu comment ça fonctionne et en fait
c'est pour ça que voir dans un différend
rôle est différent parce que cette
année-là faste et paolo gontero ou
jeremy roach ou wendell moore et john
griffin était un soldat de complément
pas très vocal ce qu'il était par le
passé donc il peut se muer dans un rôle
de complément psychologiquement ça a pas
l'air de l'avoir dérangé je pense qu'ils
étaient surtout très 0 est très soulagée
de jouer en fait ça ne s'était vraiment
ce qu'il transpirait dans entre moi et
après je trouve que c'est une vraie
force aussi d'être capable de voir
justement de s'adapter au contexte
outils quand même beaucoup
d'intelligence et pas noire et de savoir
vivre voire de savoir être dans fils de
gauche il ya aussi souvent c'est quand
même aussi des garçons qui ont une
certaine rigueur et qui prennent là
parce qu'on veut bien leur laisser je
pense par exemple à d'autres comme hard
jose qui est aussi un fils de coach un
de mes choux dernière les sculptures des
questions romain sur le profil de jean
guy finn est ce que c'est quelque chose
si tu vois des griffin en tête
bonne foi je dois
donc à jour tu es content ouais je suis
content parce que comme
comme à l'année les magnans dit on c'est
ce qui va faire
et je pense que ton lui tombé avec l'île
heard et
aussi permet d'avoir va dire moins de
pression sur le fait de devoir scorer
n'importe quelle manière
hessabi donné du temps aussi peut-être
pour bob je sais pas s'il peut encore
récupérer de ces messieurs est ce qui
peut encore
récupérer au niveau athlétique donc ça
peut aussi lui donner du temps moi j'ai
juste une petite question c'est que moi
j'ai découvert en fait j'ai découvert
des films grâce à vous sur une vraie
émission la très longue le sel vous
présentiez les cinq les cinq premiers
premier des cinq prospère et plus les
plus en vue est en fait après j'ai
découvert d'autres notamment mathurin
est en fait ce qui m'a choqué c'est la
différence de vitesse quoi je trouve
vraiment très longue des finances est en
attaque et en fait tu me demandes si et
pourtant l année plutôt des bonnes stats
notamment auprès du panier tous à la
finition si on va pas avoir en fait les
limites de sa plus belle
tenue
ça c'est possible effectivement mais son
on en revient à la blessure qui quitte
le retrouvera jamais le on retrouvera
jamais le joueur qu'il était il ya deux
trois ans si vous voulez voir ce que
c'était aller voir les compils fiba où
il était avec lui c'est america où il a
estimé que ces pardons ou voilà c'est un
genre totalement différent de ce qu'on a
vu cet été que c'est cette année et
c'est une vraie question parce que c'est
légitime parce que
c'est c'est le groupe point on sait
qu'on n'aura jamais on retrouvera jamais
et la question c'est est ce qu'il va
arriver à le retrouver même un tout
petit peu donc ce sera jamais 100% mais
est-ce qu'il peut retrouver 80% à 75% de
ça
et là dessus moi je dis faut attendre
mais en fait si c'est un risque si un
des plus gros risque delà de la draft et
high risk reward avec lui mais le risque
en vaut pour moi le risque en vaut la
peine mais je pense même si le space
singh peut vraiment l'aider à eux nba
est ce que moi j'ai une question pour
vous manuel est ce qu'il ya un monde où
à jean guy finn descend plus plus plus à
cause de son dossier médical je pense
par exemple à notre france éthique avait
beaucoup descendus le soir de la draft à
cause de ça visiblement puisque c'est
des situations un peu comparable
il ya une situation il sort de la
loterie ouais je pense qu'ils les
retours sont négatifs et oui aux
spécificités ses genoux et pied c'est
quand même c'est pas un pouce ou un un
coude même si c'est important le coude
pour shooter
lui met un genou et un pied et quand un
joueur qui était basé sur l'explosivité
un agent qui a pris du poids aussi
qu'est devenu plus lourd on en parlait
moins explosif c'est vrai il a perdu
cette explosivité parce qu'avant en fait
il faisait déjà deux mètres très jeune
on voit m 98 et et on peut s'exposer là
en fait il apparaît un peu et
l'expressivité l'a gagnée sur le haut du
corps hors tabac explique défensivement
pour moi de plus amené à défendre les
3/4 que les 2/3 en nba mais le truc qui
la revend développés qui pour moi fait
qu'il doit rester je pense à un
prospecteur c'est la qualité de tir un
mec de deux mètres qui tire aussi bien
en catch and shoot donc il peut vivre
sans la balle qui n'a que 18 ans donc il
ya toujours pour moi plus de potentiel
que j'adore ça reste ça c'est primordial
mais il ya un monde où ils servent à
l'autriche clairement je crois que
michael porter junior il se fait drafté
quoi la torre brève limite d'anders la
faille sortir va l'offrir donc je
compare pas rejoindre une équipe qui
avait deux pics il invite mémoire avait
12 et 14 l'équipe
et c'est drafté par denver puisque clic
les clippers ne prennent pas les
clippers gréver prochaine et jérôme
rudin
0 donc
il ya un monde où il descend clairement
il ya un nom de me descendre ou et août
où l'équipe qui leur a agrafé diront
tout sera labellisé comme l'équipe pour
à fait le style de alors menace ouais ça
sera toujours ça
on n'a pas parlé aussi de quelque chose
qui est assez particulier
garçons c'est sa technique de tir les
gens
j'aime bien qu'on y revienne parce que
c'est quand même niveau des gens c'est
assez incroyable moi j'ai jamais vu de
mémoire la chine j'ai beau chercher des
joueurs avec des appuis aussi écarté la
rue lorsqu'il tiers juge je n'ai pas vu
ça j'ai pas souvenir c'est pas si vous
avez des noms je n'agis pas soutenir et
ça c'est très particulier au niveau de
la mairie de thiers si vous l'avez
jamais vu ces des applications on dit
généralement au basket c'est l'argent
des pauvres à saissac on dit dans les
yeux et lui c'est bien supérieur en aide
à leurs amis da ble ssé pyramidale
utilisée à une expression la tour eiffel
alan vraiment très à propos
de prospecter et g
mais ça sent pas comme quoi parce qu'on
a des menus 46% catch and shoot c'est
fluide je pense quand même que le staff
qui va le prendre va les faire changer
ça je pense qu'il y aura travaillé sur
moi ce que tu as tu ce qui me gêne c'est
que ça lui empêche un peu de tirs entre
dans son dribble web ou bien pour le
plus de mal à poulets parfaite parce
qu'il arrive me l'a jamais la bonne
forme de tirs ça rend possible il n'aura
jamais si c'est celle ci il l'aura
jamais en course s'est jouée c'est
vraiment comme ça c'est bizarre les
juifs genou se touchent presque quoi
c'est assez étonnant mais 60
fonctionnaires
là à voir si c'est physiquement si c'est
facile à changer
si vous avez des questions sur les
prospects qu'on évoque n'hésitez pas
allez poser leur histoire et 10 griffin
on va passer un une fausse perron mains
c'est bon pour toi le profil est claire
et détaillée ouais ça te va on va passer
à celui qui a une cote qui ne cesse de
monter
d'avouer antimines night c'est dyson
daniels
dyson daniels c'est parti menu présente
nous cette nouvelle sensation
australienne nouvelle parce que je pense
à l'ami jo je dis ok ici ouais c'est pas
le même type de joueur
d'abord c'est un grand meneur je le
considère comme manière en grand bonheur
de deux mètres d'envergure de 2,8
un joueur comme moi j'apprécie notamment
la la défense c'est vraiment là qui m'a
plu plus
le visuel m'a vraiment impressionné là
tu sais sur sa ds capacités défensives
sur sur les extérieurs 1 et 2 ou sur des
joueurs bâti des anciens
ben c'est pas défaut du tout qu elle
n'était pas du tout ridicule donc c'est
vraiment ça qui comme moi j'apprécie
vraiment le joueur donc c'est vraiment
ça qui me le mettre le maître haut et
c'est aussi un vrai meneur en
particulier la pression aussi donc c'est
un très bon dans le playbook est une
très bon dans le jeu de transition et
qui a une marge de progression dans
quasiment tout ce qu'il sait faire et ça
c'est vraiment un prêt appréciable et
aussi le sur le tir à longue distance
cgp aller si ses stats sous les yeux la
sueur pour lui mais si il ajouté
vraiment c'était vraiment intéressant
c'est un plat dessus c'est vraiment
intéressant et c'est la question sur lui
c'est comment l'intégrer ce pour le même
porteur de balle principal est ce qu'il
est ce qu'il était cette année
quand il jouait avec angie league ou est
ce qu'il arrivera à être ce
second l'initiateur c'est vraiment plus
à un rôle qui moi me
m'interpelle internet comment bien le
faire jouer trouver le le rôle qui lui
sera bénéfique pour gagner des mutés
avoir plusieurs contrées en nba et pour
résumer grossièrement ses bourreaux
défenseur sur les postes extérieurs à et
2 plein meeting une belle capacité ocha
son tir de mémoire était quand même
souvent un petit peu dans l'oeil du
cyclone alan était un petit peu décrié
parce que notre pas beaucoup c'est pas
quelqu'un qui lit ni ses plus ardents à
un mec un peu basses first et qui aime
bien tout ce qui est ironique l'auteur
patron du cercle non ouais ouais
clairement clairement
moi j'aime pas son dribble je pense pas
qu'il peut dribbler une billets à bas à
niveau décent pour qu'on lui donne la
balle et puis depuis ce 1er décision
action infraction ce qui me dérange pas
d'ailleurs parce que vadim annulé
tellement fort défensivement sur les
phases 1 2 3 il commence à mettre en
catch and shoot et c1 ce que j'appelle
un connecteur c'est à dire que c'est
toujours un genre qui fait la bonne
passe je fais la passe avant la passe
décisive qui ralentit jamais le jeu car
une très bonne vision qui est très bon
sur comme caddie flotteurs lieners tous
les intervalles qui est un bon toucher
quand on l'a on l'a déjà vu être leader
de son équipe il a été avec l'australie
dont les 19 qui a fait un excellent
fonds a d'ailleurs avec avec cette
équipe-là qui servirait que la dgid et
guy night compte des pros contre des
kundé père de famille s'était parfois
compliqué pour lui d'avoir la balle dans
les mains et il s'est plutôt muet en
swing dit couteau suisse toujours la
bonne passe et voir dans le bon temps ce
qui fait que on peut se dire bah
peut-être que il va il sera peut-être
d'un côté sera toujours utile dans un
rôle et dans un contexte et dans l'autre
peut-être qu'il a ce potentiel parce
qu'il reste jeune et parce qu'on a déjà
vu plus jeune femme assumer des
responsabilités aux principes moraux
jade j'adore jones et pour moi c'est le
meilleur prospect de ziggy night cette
année parce que c'est plus ans érable
facilement dans un collectif n'diaye des
choses sans la balle avec la balle il
peut tirer et défensivement il est super
impressionnant doublé franchement en
entendant cette somme ça me choquerait
de moins en moins tellement j'aime bien
tenu
donc tu l'as dit un petit peu toi tu as
passé un connecteur moi j'appelle ça
plutôt un fluidifiant un poste à compter
de
fin d'année qui rentrent en équipe
mineure est ce que quelque part il n'y a
pas un petit peu
évidemment il n'a pas beaucoup dé voir
comme ça on aime bien est-ce que c'est
pas un peu comme le nuancier
c'est ça moi il est ce que je voyais de
venir tant les animaux comment fais tu
as les meilleurs fans est devenu super
fort balle en main on avait tous des
petits doutes bien sûr mais je pense pas
qu'il deviendra ce qui était un ami
burton balle au rebond puisque sur le
piano
c'est un excellent joueur mais je
pensais que peut avoir ce rôle de
connecteurs toujours toujours utile peut
tirer peut passer peut dribbler le
niveau médian ce qui est des rites sous
les pleurs
finalement il a pas tant que ça a fini
en forte hausse ce niveau là il se
trouve ce qu'ils disent ils apportent
directement c'est un gros qi basket vous
dirais aussi qu'il faut ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est ma active en défense
qu'il ait des mains très très rapide il
c'est quelque chose qu'on va pas trop
fan des fois un peu à l'espagnol invités
revoir sa côté positif les harkis
beaucoup avec avec les mains après avoir
comment ça peut se traduire au niveau de
ces petits matins elle peut sanctionner
haut débit mais je trouve ça vraiment
assez intéressant
comment on imagine attirer ce genre de
profil romain à portland est ce que ça
peut faire la malle ou pas du tout pour
moi à partir du moment où un excellent
défenseur tu devrais pas avoir trop de
mal à s'insérer dans importants
notamment notamment sur les postes
extérieurs parce que
c'est toujours notre gros problème
il n'ya pas vous n'a pas vraiment de
joueurs pour pourvoir les porteurs de
balle adverse
donc de règne pour sa marge est quasi
j'ai pas trop doute sur le fait qu'ils
puissent intégrer même en attaque c'est
à dire que même si on voit pas comme un
porteur de balle près la primaire
normalement important dit il le sera pas
et en revanche ce que je trouve alors
peut-être qui pour le coup il est trop
jeune pour fit la timeline de taylor
mais si on pense plutôt à en faire une
semaine je pense que le conseil ne s'est
pas
comme dirait un playmaker first plutôt
un scoreur et je pense que quelqu'un qui
peut lui qui peut l'aider comme vous
disiez à fluidifier le jeu et c'est moi
je le vois comme un complément parfait
on finit dans quelques années quoi donc
ça prendra peut-être un peu plus de
temps que pour des queues pour mettons
griffin il qu'à un tir déjà
très très efficace mais j'ai pas
vraiment de doute sur le fait qu'ils
puissent incorporé dans l'équipe un peu
plus tard quoi pas forcément mais dans
quelques années
on n'a pas trop parlé de la menthe et
était lui un sont là aussi on a vu quand
même donc plusieurs rôles tu l'as dit
alain tout à l'heure avec l'équipe
d'australie en tant que leader contre
compte des pères de famille pour
reprendre l'expression
inec où il n'était pas non plus la star
de l'équipe
comment il arrive à se comporter ces
quelques jours de deux joueurs ils sont
là c'est
zen fin c'est tout ensuite elle a lui
même j'ai l'impression n'est pas
quelqu'un qui monte dans les tours c'est
quelqu'un de stable
maintenant c'est un il est très calme
très calme pas très expressif
il a quand même pris un risque en
réalité a fait au revenant avec des lits
denied parce que j'aurais pu rester en
australie en fait le programme next aux
curiosités parce que c'est quand même
sortir un taux de sa zone de confort
mais c'est toujours positif chez
certains prospère ne repousse un peu ce
n'est pas ce que c'est en fait ce qui
reste en australie son aventure dans un
cocon dans six ou jazzy des tous ces
gens là ils étaient dans un cocon donc
de plus en plus ailleurs il change de il
sort d'un jeune de confort parce que le
groupe prochain tarik proctor il va
jouer à duke donc c'est intéressant de
voir ça mais je trouve que wade est allé
dans un contexte où il savait qu'il
aurait pas la balle est en fête
ça s'était bien passé parce qu'il s'est
adapté il a rendu son équipe meilleure
des zones d'agnès comment on explique sa
hype qui est depuis deux semaines
comment ça se fait que d'accous ya signé
7 cet élan d'amour sur dyson daniels
puisque les gens se mettent enfin à
garder la vie lit à regarder les matchs
ou est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui brille
le lors des workouts lors des entretiens
et se plaît c'est par rapport au retour
est ce qu'on faisait les infos sur sa
dégaine
pas perso mais je pense que c'est les
très stable sur le condamne sur les
bords comme en font ils montent un peu
mais il commençait déjà à monter sur la
fin de saison on a fini la saison
ou là des gens ont commencé à plus en
plus entendre son nom
c'est un tout je pense c'est un tout et
c'est un mec caisse est cependant pour
moi c'est important c'est qu'est il
connaît déjà le plus ou moins le monde
professionnel elle a été habituée et à
19 ans et pas c'est pas négligeable même
si là une scie et c'est quand même du
semi pro pro enfin une semi pro plus
là il a déjà le il a déjà le truc qui
l'habitude au terrain avec l'habitude à
la ligne à trois points il a habitué à
avoir un staff autour de lui l'habitude
a omis en nba
ça peut être à un plus aussi pour lui
une que messieurs vous avez encore des
choses à dire sur notre ami australien
ou d'autres questions euros mais
non juste dire que balle et on sait
qu'il a faim à voir carte avec ouais
alors c'était pas un workout solo mais
il est accompagné de joueurs mais en
tout cas là il a fait remarquer au tapin
fait
qu'effectivement ça peut être vraiment
une option cette
messieurs on va passer à un autre profil
un profil plus scoreur en la personne de
johnny davis
manu je compte sur toi pour la
présentation ses cris
ganic des lycéens
le pour le coup c'est plus en arrière
ailier ou qu'annonce à deux mètres on
est en mesure de 2,08 très intéressant
actifs ou 8 c'est vraiment un
scoreur first où il est vraiment très
très bon là dedans c'est vraiment un
gars de 19 ans qui sait déjà tout faire
rôtir catch and shoot poule up mais il
est vraiment très très complexe
notamment à à 1000 distance ou
où aller il a été formidable tout au
long de l'année sur sa deuxième année de
2 avec wisconsin mais c'est vraiment là
son rond point fort c'est sa capacité à
savoir tirer dans tous les sens donc
c'est vraiment un super intéressant là
dessus jarque est assez bon aussi of
ball dans des deux côtés du terrain donc
ça c'est pas négligeable non plus qui
est agressif il s'étirait mais il va
aussi au cercle donc ça c'est super
important aussi le petit entre
guillemets hic ça va être le s qui parce
que dans la nba actuelle si on va
demander à les grands maintenant fin les
grands les postes extérieurs savent
initiés et c'est vraiment là le le
cheval de la chose pour moi il doit
encore progresser c'est dans ce pays me
king ou cette année on l'a pas trop trop
trop vu balle en main ou quand il est là
il la garde trois secondes donc c'est
vraiment pas lui qui initiait le truc
qui a remonté la balle il passait la
ligne de mithat il passait son ballon et
il allait se placer il allait faire son
truc c'est vraiment ça qui va qui va
pouvoir le faire gagner des minutes avec
un
avec un staff line biais savoir le
modelé là dessus sur ce permis kings est
aussi un à trois points est ce qu'il va
réussir à avoir cette fiabilité à trois
points qu'il a remis distance c'est en
termes de coût par exemple le
leur dire ça le jeu le joueur pourrait
avoir si tout se passe bien c'est une
sorte de davy nduka
sort des bimbos coeur et moi j'avais
j'avais lu et j'ai repris ce prêt avait
lu des gens qu'il comparait à cj michael
non pas que je sois d'accord mais vu
qu'on parle de portland forcément
le tic l'adriatique et puis le côté
joueur qui tire à mi distance
défensivement il c'est un joueur qui se
comporte comme ans
plutôt bien c'est pas un c'est pas un
foudre de guerre c'est pas le meilleur
défenseur de tous les temps mais qui
qu'intéressant enfin c'est pas un point
négatif ça a peut être un point faible
de l'équipe
mais ça va être limité sur sa sur sa
capacité à
de polyvalence il capable de faire que
sur de l'arrière pour moi s'il n'est pas
assez bon latéralité pour drive de
contenir des meneurs et pas assez encore
puissants pour garder d occuper d'être
délié ou d'ailier forte c'est celle à
couzeix limites et c'est sur ce point de
vue là défensif ce qui va arriver à un
creusement polyvalent à prendre contre
nîmes et du coffre haut du corps pour
conserver être solide sur le poste bas
c'est sur l'homme sur des joueurs entre
guillemets pas trop rapide à faire la
faire c'est vraiment le stade supérieur
parce que le potentiel défensif il il
faudra gratter là dessus
pour moi la ddt est ce que c'est un
joueur qu'on a vu beaucoup secret de tir
à mi distance on retrouve comme l'a dit
manu est ce que ça se l'imaginent
transposer a si rapidement au next level
je pense qu'il ya dans ses premières
années en nba lors un rôle entre ce
qu'ils avaient stagné à risque
continuent et le rôle qu'il avait bon le
voit sur la photo avec team usa ou 1019
où ils jouent avec l'idée naïve et
chattam rennes est en fait où il a été
un peu l'été de louga y ait eu ndi
feront pas beaucoup de tirs coupe samba
le monde défend pour ça que je l'étais
je n'étais pas super sur le problème
c'est que prendra cette salle est un
joueur nba mais ça va plutôt un joueur
de complément simplement bon ben là un
vrai complément et cette année la montre
et ben ouais ça reste est allé sur son
midrange capacité à pouvoir être
restauré un influent dans une équipe
nombreuses conférences dentelle parce
que ce le rôle se situe là dedans
pas que j'ai une devise va arriver à une
bille et écran d'une tonne de minerai
d'or parce que c'est des shoots qui sont
réservées aux superstars et d2 puisque
je pense pas que
c'est qu'il fera de ses possessions des
choses positives à auxerre par action
moi je pense que c'est un genre beaucoup
plus polyvalent qu'on pouvait le penser
il ya un an c'est un joueur qui peut
s'insérer qu'une bonne mentalité je
pense c'est un peu comme dan daniels en
fait ces deux joueurs je trouve qu'ils
sont en mission il saute pas aux yeux
sur l'airé light ils fondent pas ils
font pas des choses extrêmement
incroyable mais ils sont bons voire très
bons dans plusieurs domaines qui font
qu'on sorte un collectif c'était pas des
potentiels star incroyable mais plutôt
des très solides joueurs doués
même si on aime beaucoup les hauts
potentiels les risques sont des joueurs
avec des planches et sur ce
que le roma c'est un profit qui intrigue
fois le fan des déserts c'est celui que
j'ai le moins que gaël main
comme ça de loin j'ai l'impression aussi
passionné pour confirmer que c'est
peut-être celui qui est peut-être le
plus redondants avec un joueur comme on
sunshine pas vraiment le profil de jeu
donc c'était peut-être le seul hic est
que plus de faire doublon je sais pas c
est ce que je dors là avec il fait plus
qui fait quatre vendeuses m donc ouais
il est différent sur l'office et
peut-être qu'il pourra jouer 23.1
d'oublier plus que l'un d'eux je veux
vraiment de l'attak 12 contre ce n'était
pas très bonne franchement c'était pas
vraiment car beaucoup de choses un peu
bizarre en données coeur qui arrive pop
a beaucoup de pick and roll et où donc
pense que dans un contexte nous meilleur
pour lui et en nba il peut vraiment
avoir ça ça mars son arsenal offensif
bien plus intéressant mais il n'a pas
pas de stars potentielles je pense ça
sera très bon pour
toi qui l'a vu dans plusieurs contextes
justement on va revenir son sort
quand une fois comment tu juges son état
d'esprit est ce que tu as vraiment vu de
voir différents dans la mentalité
dont l'expression est que teemu essais
et où ce concept a rouvert après mois on
sera non c'était la foi mais c'était un
emploi plutôt calme c'était plutôt un
alpha ya plusieurs types d'alfa laval
fois la pente souvent totalement est à
la fois
excentrique mais tu as aussi l'alpha
leader par l'exemple et des bus était
plutôt là dedans et quantitatives mais
c'est en fait c'était plutôt l'équipe de
thé de nay vie puisque c'est cette
équipe de djeddah et vides cannettes
l'automne et de et de ce genre là plutôt
que l'équipe de chat ou de données
volées les autres cas il suffirait que
ce qu'ils se sont vraiment
alors c'est positif pour cech le portier
pour j'attendais vie de johnny hallyday
je trouve qu'ils se sont bien intégrés
quand j'étais là pour gagner gagner
gagner
est-ce que
je rappelle le site dans lequel faisait
des questions n'hésitez pas à poser
d'une des listes c'est pas celui dont on
a plus parlé pour être honnête on est
plus ou moins au dessus on a eu des
grandes discussions inter sur savoir si
on croyait ou non en johnny davis
manu toi tu as combien d'entre aux bords
de seine
médecin joueurs qui partent flashy pour
ça qu'on n'a pas trop un monstre je vais
13 mois je pense qu on en parle beaucoup
plus aux états unis pourquoi il a
tellement
en fait c'est par le régime il est très
bon dans ce qu'il fait et ça c'est quand
même super intéressant et on est obligé
de le considérer
moi je les deux tiers 3 donc mon père
qui va de 6 à 18 jeunes et info milieu
tu peux le comprendre en fait je pas du
tout choquée vraiment pas
est ce que il ya d autres questions
romain sueur d'uriné lice
bonjour n'a
sans doute profite à
dire vu donc je rappelle on a déjà parlé
de la dgi griffin on n'a pas aidé avant
dyson d'agnès là on a évoqué
johnny davis
tout ça c'est plutôt pour des postes
extérieurs bien sûr
maintenant on va on va s'attaquer à
un peu plus long sur 2 intérieur qui
pourrait être ce niveau-là
ski intérieur c voilà c'est prenez le
terme générique
ça va être de notre ami du renne le gars
de memphis et
demeurait de keegan murray qui pourrait
même si l'annoncé en quatre ou cinq
partout on sait jamais peut glisser
est ce que on va commencer par murray
si tu veux nous présenter magnan
t'écoute de façon religieuse évidemment
cigale murray c'est un an sophomore un
vieux ce faux mort de 22 ans 2 m 032
d'envergure
c'est un
joueur qui a joué beaucoup plus à
l'intérieur sur cette saison je le peux
le faire considérer sa taille
c'est moi je le considère que plus comme
un commerce trench coat qui est vraiment
physiquement prêt à jouer demi y ait des
débats qui est capable de défendre sur
les conditions à l'intérieur voire même
quelques ailiers et les mois les moins
élite
est
un impôt d'une bonne saison à trois
points cette année sa deuxième passe sa
première saison cette année gâchée
quasiment à 40% à 3 points sur quasiment
cinq tentatives contre 30% sur cette
année freshman sur deux tentatives
il ya une jolie
marquer dans d'un peu partout en
finalement qui est pas flashy non plus
c'est un bon athlète qui va devoir
apprendre à faire un bon jeu de passes
du preez meeting fit ses reins pour moi
c'est un joueur moyen plus un peu
partout mais le ce qui me gêne c'est son
c'est son âge 22 ans depuis lors à 22
ans quand il jouera en nba leur à 22 ans
pour 1 s'offre au nord c'est à dire qu'à
l'âge d'un senior en gros
c'est ce plus qui me gêne c'est le moins
le vois mal à voir un potentiel
par rapport aux places dans lesquelles
on voit la top 10 c'est plus ça qui
vient la presse est en soi c'est un
joueur intéressant mais là c'est mon
avis personnel je ne le vois pas faire
des choses qui élite je ne vois pas
faire des choses qui le font on le
considère comme un homme à notre
hippiques
qu'est ce qui fait selon trois que
justement tout le monde annonce aussi ou
en fait moi c'est
qu'on est un petit peu tous dubitatif
par rapport à sa caisse commence et
comme on explique la hype qui gagnerait
moi j'aime dans cette vidéo c'est son
fond je sais c'est pas forcément la
bonne expression de son jeu tire glee
capable de tirer d'un peu près toutes
les façons et 1 il a quasiment gagné de
file a gagné 10 points eu de réussite à
trois points
en un an c'est quand même assez
incroyable en shootant fois plus
moi je pense que c'est plus ça
en fait c'est vraiment c'est sous son
tir qui a fait que aua tient mais en
ceux qui suivent ayo à la big ten dans
notre équipe en parlait déjà en fin de
saison dernière
donc finalement c'est pas un joueur qui
sort de nulle part c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a progressé la sueur au
fil de ces deux ans donc ça peut aussi
dire quelque chose de très positif c'est
qu'un jour là il avance à son rythme
mais et ça se trouve dans cinq ans ça
peut être un limite all stars comme ça
peut être un joueur de centre ben quoi
pour moi c'est vraiment essayé
un risque moyen en fait il a déjà
planché plus ou moins haut donc on sait
ce qu'on aura moi j'ai plus mal à la
voir dans le futur en fait ces mecs
comme ça des espèces de twinner qui ont
pas la taille pour jouer à un poste et
pas le physique pour jour un autre j'ai
toujours eu du mal là dessus et sur le
match vu moi j'ai rien vu de flasher en
fait c'est plus sympa c'est un truc
c'est quoi lui je peux le prendre demain
un an et demi et peuvent dans ce rôle a
entouré d'un tel type de joueur c'est ça
après chacun aura son avis différent ben
nador par exemple donc
si c'est selon là c'est vraiment petit
combat en amour anthony mais sur le s
que alan tu as eu plus le coup de foudre
pour l'ami qui gagnerait et si tu peux
répondre à la question de l'estival
ski et latéralement comment ils bougent
comment il défend
pas très bien
patricia la maman
comme tous les genres d'iowa depuis très
longtemps
non j'ai pas le coup de foudre mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que keegan vrai c'est
le plug and play
on va qui par excellence sur tout notre
effectif comme importante parce qu'il
est fort sur pick'n pop parce qu'il est
fort sur pick'n roll à la finition et
qui serait servi par soit des manières
de simons donc c'est typiquement le
genre de joueur qui s'il se fait drafté
par maintenant on y va poser du 15,8 sa
saison rookie mais il le fera à 22 ans
vous qu'il est tout de suite capable
d'apporter en attaque c'est ce que je
pense que dans une grave tout pour
beaucoup de spécialistes usc une draft
acat donc bonne graine smith banquiers
rawhi vie eh ben il est le 5e parce
qu'en fait il est celui qu'il pense être
capable d'apporter dès l'an prochain
parce qu'il luttera dominé la slovénie
sied quasiment 23 9 de moyenne dans une
pose conférence est a excellemment bien
commencé il ya bien finie aussi donc
je pense que les
facteurs de l'ag déployer moins
important pour certains scouts que
d'autres le facteur
est le facteur qui soit capable très
heureux de s'implanter dessus dans un
système anniviers pesé offensivement
et c'est je pense très recherchés je ne
compare pas à ruashi mois pour moi il
est ce que les gens voyaient en ruine
chinois gonzague a aussi c'est à dire un
joueur qui peut arriver tout de suite et
faisait offensivement surtout style mais
contre des banques par exemple être
vraiment très bon donc on a dit manip 1
1 pour un bon plancher pas un un plafond
incroyable voilà moi je le drap ferait
en 15 quoi
entre 12 et 15 cette simple aux
romains je vais revenir vers toi
qu'est-ce que ça tu aspires électronique
qui gagnent leur i see that as tu as
quelque chose d'assez c'est ça m'inspire
mais c'est que voilà comme j'ai dit au
début c'est qu'il a une petite côte dans
la fanbase parce que on voit
effectivement
quel rôle pour elle pour être titulaire
en fait il pourrait rentrer jouer 4 à
côté de niort cleach
le le problème que j'ai avec lui c'est
que pour moi c'est c'est si tu le prends
c'est tu fais pas vraiment le choix tu
choisis pas vraiment présent puisque
présent ça serait de traîner ton pic et
tu choisis pas vraiment futur non plus
donc après c'est peut-être un peu dur
avec lui mais
mais ouais je mange pas très fan je
trouve que c'est tropicaux fit est passé
au passé au potentiel est aussi
ce qui est est ce qui a été rapporté de
duke ronin quand il était assistant gm
et ses séquelles il était toujours là
personne qui poussait pour
choisir le en gros le le prospect plus
risquer quoi en gros il il a toujours
été celui qui donne au chip ou c'est
pour le
et du coup ben qui gagnent mairesse
s'est pas vraiment
[Musique]
du coup
j'ai un doute sur le fait qu'on soit
vraiment
alors du coup son un profileur et qu'un
risque un peu plus élevé on a notre ami
d'israël le pivot de memphis
manu je te laisse continuer de
réprésentation tu es superbe
je remercie monsieur
nokia inaugural donc qu'est là c'est
vraiment un
d'intérieur pur qu'à la taille d'un
pivot fin dans l'intérieur de 11,2 26
d'envergure donc c'est un beau bébé de
113 kg c'est un joueur donc qu'il ait
joué à memphis cette année sous
baignarde ah ouais donc là c'est là moi
c'était là c'est mon au point noir
c'est qu'il n'a pas été utilisé de la
façon
dont il doit être l'être il a est il l'a
utilisée comme un comme un pivot lambda
ou death cool tu restes dans la peinture
sont cerclés telops catcheur et masta
pas donc alors que c'est un joueur qui
potentiellement peut faire beaucoup plus
que ça donc ultra athlétique qui est là
et on a vu la photo des harkis la faim
voire 40 avec les les blenders où la
photo de ses bras est assez
impressionnante il ya du doublé de
volume déjà par rapport à memphis
athlètes plus plus très très bon rim
protector
j'aime beaucoup cette capacité là donc
ils avaient plus de deux blocs cette
année avec memphis
c est pour moi ça 4 pas si son potentiel
le point de potentiel à travailler ça va
être ça son tir j'ai beaucoup vu en high
school avec monde verdes où il qu'on
commençait déjà à voir du minerai ont
ils en prenaient pas beaucoup mais il en
prenait c'était super intéressant avec
memphis c'est venu tard dans la saison
mais c'est venu et sati donc ça prouve
qu'ils ont pas encore gratter là dessus
et la chose que j'aime beaucoup aussi
c'est son jeu de passes en pivot c'est
vraiment très bon passeur qui va être
capable de faire la passe aux gars qui
coup d'aller chercher à l'opposé c'est
c'est super intéressant pas pressé c'est
encore assez brut c'est un joueur qui
doit encore apprendre à jouer au basket
un endroit pas seulement parce que
cacher c'est très peu de trois points
voire pas du tout c'est un joueur qui
est capable pour l'instant de défendre
suppression du poste intérieur même si
on a vu par phase aller les gêner du
porteur de balle le temps que son
coéquipier reviennent le temps d'une
mise en place de bien suivre
latéralement c'est assez c'est assez
correct pour un joueur de ce gabarit
et ça m'a pas choqué en termes de
lenteur j'ai même été surpris par
rapport à ce que j'avais vu
sur un monde ouvert dans high school
c'est pas un défenseur il va pas aller
choper le porteur de balle il n'a pas
les défendre sur open georges je vous
dis pas ça mais c'est plus moi je le
cantonne à + 4/5 va défendre occupes toi
de ces gars-là est sûre du pick n'roll
il sera capable d'aller gêner le porteur
de balle sur quelques secondes on doit
vraiment de gêne et l'initiation du pic
donc c'est un genre que moi j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup peut-être un peu trop
gelé très haut dans mon boire
quelque chose comme ça mais c'est un
joueur auquel je crois beaucoup
défensivement et à la passe et je vois
j'ai envie de croire en ti au tir donc
je ne sais pas son pourcentage aux
lancers francs et patin droit de mémoire
62% sais pas où ce qui est bien pour à
l'intérieur mais c'est pas c'est pas
dingue
c'est à l'agglo
s'il devait tracer en voilà en trois
mots ses rimes protector un peu de tirs
loeb catcheur voilà près du cercle très
très bon et capable de faire la bonne
passe
est-ce que ça ça peut s'intégrer
directement
portland est ce que ça peut jouer des
minutes mbiye ces très jeunes aussi on
l'a pas la jeune que la draft il arrive
à 18 ans
la wii est donc est ce que il peut jouer
en année une des minutes conséquent
trendy
faut qu'il soit qu'on peut mais faut
qu'ils soient accompagnés du bond pivot
donc fort enfants un pivot qui s'écarte
un peu voilà qui capable de craquer
parce que c'est pas lui qui va écarter
le jeu est pour toi c'est plus un 14
non ça en cinq
sets sans évoquer ses 1,5 mais où loi ou
faut qu'il faut qu'il joue son
coéquipier françois son partenaire à
l'intérieur faut qu'ils soient capables
d'écarter le jeu autrement il sera pas
forcément utile ça va être un mec qui va
faire du pick and roll donc c'est pas
non seulement
secours cherchent qu'on croit moi je me
rends loterie c'est mon avis là dessus
mais
moi je crois fort au potentiel surtout
en fait je vois un mec qui va être
capable de shooter à terme et qui va
être capable de
faire trois blocks par match et qui va
être capable de le passer
je parle j'ai pas de comparaison parce
que je sais pas trop comment mais je
sais dans ma tête
j'arrive à l'expliquer cette can allofs
faut écouter alan pascal and déteste les
pivots 1000 m
j'allais remonter parce que je sais que
je connais
ô combien sa philosophie sur les pieds
vous surtout sur ce genre de pivot je
veux ton avis aux jeunes du raid
s'il n'avait pas les flashs à la passe
et les flashs au tenir je ne prends pas
en loterie
mais il les a donc c'est un intrépide
pour moi c'est un très vite parce que
de mettre 11,2 m 26 d'envergure 113 kg
113 kg il n'est pas en étant pas gros il
est
bien batié il est très solide donc
en fait je pense que challenger n
j'avais écrit un article seront en
décembre j'avais dit est-ce que voilà ce
type de pivot la vo une sélection top 5
alors top cinq sinon c'est un peu pour
labelliser est en fait je pense que il
est exactement ce que ce qui était sonné
cocon goût pour moi il ya deux ans en
fait c'est c'est les deux seuls
intérieur qui sont pas que je
qualifierais pas de génération que
j'accepte ce serait 3 dernière draft de
prendre dans le top10 pourquoi parce que
ils ont alors l'obstacle défensif
protection de cercle et là
et ils ont soit la passe soit le tir
pour vraiment être plus que juste un
finisseur un catcheur de la bretagne du
renne comme a dit manu on l'a vu au
lycée on y voyait un peu avec memphis
prendre mes distances prendre du turner
en namibie ce sens la violence et france
amélioré sur la saison la vue est
capable de prendre des décisions sur
short rolls à dire c'est un passeur avec
beaucoup de déchet il fait deux fois
plus d hyper nette deux fois plus de
ballons que deux pas sixième l'an
dernier et comme il est doux comme un
agneau de contexte memphis et et
parvient pas d'esprit singh pas trop de
bons meneurs pour le mettre dans les
bons et moins de situations mais on a vu
des flashs à la passe des flashs à la
parce que tout le monde a vu et qui font
que il sera pas simplement
moi il peut être mais en fait il peut
être robert williams sous stéroïdes et
robert roux diable
cet homme c'est cet indice parce que
robert louisiane c'est un
insensé genou robert williams s'est
vraiment je pense que ça c'est un
des meilleurs pivots défensive dernier
donc
ses marges exactement te dire ça je vais
te dire pingo qui met des contres
athlétique avec des flashs annaba ça me
fait beaucoup penser ou publics boston
mais sa cote du raid en plus il a
potentiellement le midrange qui est à
noter qu'à une très bonne il n'avait pas
trop les soucis d'ailleurs hors terrain
qui ailleurs robert boulin de saint-ex à
cnn il a été un an plus tôt à menphis ça
s'est très bien passé alors qu'il a
quand même passé son année où un bout de
son année alors qu'elle est encore que
17 ans et tous les soucis avec les mots
ni bay s'ils avaient tous les soucis
avec tenir à dos et lui l'a pas fait
d'après mes réussi à faire sa saison
complète dans un contexte qui n'était
pas bon on peut le dire donc non
franchement le jeune andy rain c'est si
portland veut
tenter un gros coup à l'intérieur ans
est franchement ils peuvent le prendre
pour le prendre mais je vais pas traîné
j'ai crié puisque romain tu ne vas pas
crier non plus ils prennent durée dans
cette non je crée pas non plus
j'aime bien profile après sur les
minutes qui peut prendre je sais pas
parce que déjà que quand défense on
n'est pas très bon donc six ans il a
besoin d'un panda prendre
ça peut être un peu compliqué pour lui
mais par contre
on a rien comme lui et en plus il serait
sûrement backup de neuf donc ça pourrait
lui permettre de dire de se faire à la
nba plutôt contre des seconds j'ai dit
voilà on va dire voilà moins de pression
un peu un peu moins de temps et d un peu
moins de temps sur le terrain mais du
coup plus de temps pour travailler pour
s'améliorer mais encore une fois ce
serait aussi
pour une place dans le futur que
on envisage que tout de suite quoi
du coup est-ce que ça c'est très gênant
quelqu'un qui soit pas pour l'expression
le gameplay est ce que c'est
c'est quelque chose justement bas on
sait que des mines ou trauma réseau
voilà donc est ce qu'il n'ya pas cette
crise toi aussi pour moi à partir du
moment où on n'échange pas le pic et
qu'on va la draft bah c'est qu'on sait
qu'on assume ce choix là croyez que
quelque part
non en fait on alors après je sais pas
ce que c'est un miracle qu'on peut faire
après sur l'afrique dance est où là vous
parlez treille mais quelque part ça veut
dire qu'on privilégie - la thaïlande et
les larmes et plus celles potentiel
et dans ce cas là ça me gêne absolument
pas d'avoir durable dans l'effectif
est ce que
toi tu as
un profil que tu préfères entre les deux
du coup entre les gares le profil plus
près et qui gagneraient ou un fil plus
ce projet mais avec un profil que vous
avez plus à demi fou avec des rennes du
raid moins insolite et ouais moi c'est
un projet tout de suite
plus le projet n'a
eu cookies tout sauf iain murray
il ya le mur est de toute façon
quelqu'un climent parce que
effectivement comme on l'a dit c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a pas une marge de
progression en tout cas qui semblent
importantes si quelqu'un qui peut faire
bien 10 15 ans et demi ça se trouve
croissance mais aussi des profits qui
finalement quand tu l'as dit ces profils
aussi assez rare en fait il n'y a pas
tant que ça des gens qui arrivent
paragraphe des années qu'il y ait
plusieurs contrats en nba 6 ans n'ayant
peut-être aussi un bon choix
avec manu avant
attendant aux mains on parlait
du fait
que notre ami celui qui n'a pas voulu
depuis un an et demi
était en train s'entraîner visiblement à
portland alors est-ce que
alors peut-être comme dirait
le premier monte alors peut-être pour ça
peut être pas être une option aussi manu
je te laisse en parler un petit goût de
profil bas c'est ma grande théorie en
fait j'ai je puisse donc chez dan shak
donc on parle de shenzhen charpin pour
ce conte pas deviner même somme en c1 un
joueur donc a pas joué depuis un an et
demi donc arrivé à cannes tu tiens en
janvier mais cap à jouer qui s'est
entraîné normalement pas de soucis de
blessures ou quoi que ce soit quel juste
pas joué
parce que
parce qu'on lui a dit tu joues pas tu as
entre guillemets une cote à protéger
sauf que cette cote
elle a explosé en parce qu'il ya la
draft de cette année donc il accuse huit
étaient annoncées dans le top 5 de tout
le monde très très vite et moyens ce qui
me fait tilter c'est que chez ea et
spillane il a toujours été cette à
portland et puis les premières notes il
l'a encore été là ya
peut-être une semaine ou deux là ils ont
ils en ont sorti une toujours 7 alors je
me dis qu'est-ce qu'ils sont tombés en
amour avec ce gars là
parce que je me suis enfin si espionner
en l'occurrence
match métier et cela donne given in
place des joueurs comme ça tout le temps
même le poste pendant quelques mois
maintenant c'est qu'il ya forcément une
raison
qu'est ce que tu as roma tu as entendu
des choses là dessus est ce que
est ce que c'est totalement bidon ce que
je racontais je suis complètement fou où
est ce qu'il ya une possibilité est ce
qu'il ya un truc et je vous ferai un peu
le profil du joueur après
je sais juste que rencontrer
au combat avec un entretien personnel
avec qui gagnerait aussi mais je sais
que oui et un entretien et que sa part
des chars
alors pendant un moment il ya une hype
folle il était même une quasiment
annoncé top 3 donc quasiment
inatteignable pour portland et puis
petit à petit ça re ça revient vers le
set et effectivement il y a une petite
richard
et comme j'ai comme je disais aussi tout
à l'heure que jack ronin comme il est
très dense eux cette philosophie a
escaladé world
[Musique]
sharp
va là dedans quoi donc je serais pas
étonné si vraiment il descend jusqu'à 7
je serais pas du tout étonné que
ce qu'on finisse par le parlement
tu as eu la chance de le voir un peu toi
ce finalement c'est un peu un mystère
pour beaucoup parlé il faudrait pas tous
à déjouer manu tu sais quel genre de
profil ça donne ça c'est un arrière
ailier très très très athlétique qui est
cac a créé son buzz l'été dernier en
libye elle donc c'est un circuit et ou
de nike ou d'un coup d'un seul il est
devenu trop fort en fait il vaut mieux
en fait on l'a vu nous avec alan
notamment sur le film a eu une 16
america où c'était un joueur plus ou
moins landes en fait il y avait là il y
avait le heat est on disait tiens lui
faut cocher son mais y'avait pas c'était
pas wow tu pars avec mais y avait
quelque chose
est sûre le ciel ce fameux circuit
circuit à ibm il est devenu porteur de
balle initiateur shooter à trois points
à 47% et là tout le monde se dit pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc il est de
non classés il est devenu numéro 1 des
lycéens de sa catégorie d'âge
il se fait
reclassés dans la dans cette classe de
2022 donc ça veut dire qu'il a été qu'il
a fait tous les process scolaire au
lycée etc lillois il a entonné me lasson
baky c'est pas ça mais il a son bac il a
eu son bac avec un an d'avancé ou six
mois d'avancé donc il peut passer à la
fac donc là-dessus tout est clean dont
qui décide de se faire reclasser et il
va à kenzy et à tin tuc qui du coup il
joue pas
son entourage cui 98 ou pas on va voir
si parce que l'éligibilité n'était pas
100% sûr en fait quand ils les risques
crois que c'est faire classer pour une
question administrative
américaine
qui a finalement débouché sur une
éligibilité est donc là par tout le
monde se tout le monde se dit et merde
c'est qui ce gala parce que du coup pas
de film sur vous il faut aller chercher
du cese faut aller chercher dit oui elle
que les scouts ont un
mais il ya quand même un truc un mec
t'as pas vu depuis un an et demi
pourquoi tout le monde le considère
comme sa top 5 est en moi je laime
plutôt pas mal je fais je faut revoir
évidemment mais en fait le tir est
tellement fort c'est un mec athlétique
ultra band ci qui tu as la tête au
niveau de la au-dessus du cercle saint
privat au dunk
car entre temps wayne question pas à ça
de ice rabbit 94 qui ne dit par rapport
à jeff green c'est du même acabit est
éthiquement à diane greene ouais ouais
c'est
[Musique]
exclusivement athlétiquement
si le sait ça vous est un mec ultra
vendre si comme ça
wouah
mais lui contrairement à diane mirin
c'est un peu près jouer au basket c'est
un peu plus intéressant parce qu'on
attire en fait 6 e
[Musique]
tir selon la presse qu'on a pu lire sur
ces passages entre l'américaine il est
capable de passer ce qu'il faisait pas
forcément sur les ihm sur les matches
qu'on est moi parce que j'ai vu ça a été
un mach 2 capable de passer mais aussi
capable de défendre et de défendre très
très bien
donc je vous conte se dit finalement un
flat c'est vraiment un on sait pas ce
qu'on aura mais le si tout ce passe très
très bien ça peut être le meilleur
joueur de la draft soit potentiellement
alan est ce que
d'une question par rapport à ça donne
quoi son niveau mais cette éthique de
travail tout ça c'est vrai que ça se
complique à évaluer parce que non plus
c'est quelqu'un qu'on a l'impression
voire peut-être sous par rapport à ces
conseils par rapport à ces agents qui
reste très cash et d'ailleurs il n'ya
pas de rumeurs de scouts is we c'est
quoi ce gars qui se montre jamais et
c'est
donc ils scandaient des infos sur sa sur
un peu le maïs est et des titres à eto'o
qui l'a vu en live
bah
tu as un peu les deux moi ce que je veux
dire les gens qui disent qui en gros il
n'a pas une bonne éthique parce qu'il
n'a pas joué pas un argument qu'il
n'avait rien à gagner à jouer en fait
ils avaient tout à perdre que moi je
suis là ici si comme le cloud et qu'elle
fût qui ça a été un labour béant dans la
saison à cause des blessures je suis
mais shannon sharpe pas dedans s'il
n'est pas bon il se passe quoi il va
baisser dans les mac et dans l'élite
board donc il avait rien à faire en fait
puis joue il avait pas grand chose à
gagner vu que honnêtement je pense qu'il
sortira pas du top 10 donc en fait être
lottery pick établissent sans jouer bah
moi je le fais aussi
en fait je le fais si par contre il faut
comme tu comment 10 sur les interviews
sur les work out sur les rencontres avec
les mêmes les franchises par contre
rassurer sur a expliqué le pourquoi du
comment je pense que tu peux être très
honnête avec les franchises sur
certaines choses assez déjà fait un des
joueurs qui avaient refusé en finissant
mode d'ailleurs cet effet avec était
resté mg académie il était un peu
descendu à cause de ça mais ils avaient
été honnêtes sur les franchises oui la
visite franchement je n'y a pas grand
chose à gagner ayant initié
donc je pense qu'il va falloir rendre
kylie interview très bien qui
si le qui rassure les franchises sur sa
sur son entourage sur son mindset ya pas
de soucis scolaires c'est à cause de
l'école comme à 10 minutes qui s'est
passé c'est tout ce qu'en groupe
je pense qu'il a vraiment comme
planification de faire comme un mythe ou
des jaloux c'est à dire à la chine ce
qui sur la deuxième partie de là de sa
première année restez s'entraîner tous
les jours à l'odieuse est ce qui faisait
aussi été avec deron fox magiquement
qu'ils étaient restés pour l'année
d'après je pense que charles voulais
vraiment faire ça sauf qu'en ce qu'ils
veulent en quoi est ce que tu es le plan
initial on a dit chaque déchet d'hommes
sud présente t loterie bah ouais mais
faut y aller en fait il ya un contrat
garanti de 4 ans il ya des millions de
dollars en jeu donc vous y aller mais je
pense que et d'ailleurs c'était je pense
vraiment qu'il ya là parce que ça a mis
encore opéré de calipari sur sa classe
de recrutement qui est très incomplète à
cause de ça alors pas de souci pour lui
ça se passe bien on veut ça les avait
toujours pas se passe bien
je pense qu'en fait c'est la veille il
avait ce syndrome l'a7 cette envie là
mais une franchise comme a dit manu peu
tombée amoureuse du profil du joueur
qu'il est puisque de potentiel est
incroyable c'est potentiellement l'un
des plus hauts plafonds cette draft ou
sur les postes extérieurs donc
honnêtement il ya en sept jeux portland
moi j'ai pas de doute sur le nom que je
mets sur la carte
aurait d'ailleurs qu'est qui vous met
qui à titre personnel parmi les légendes
on va parler vous n'êtes pas d'ailleurs
peut-être des prospects vous fera pas
parler qui pour alan tu deviens le dire
mais qui vous prendriez sharp route de
rennes pour mon
chapeau d'uruguay
moi je veux une foule potentiel et soit
charte soit quelqu'un qu'on a pas parlé
c'est jérémy chauhan de baylor saura gré
roman pourquoi à titre personnel une
petite préférence
dans ce dont on a parlé je dirais que si
sharp est dispo je tranche à j'aime bien
dans les zones daniel ceci est dure et
ça serait mon top 3
après je sais qu'on a aussi fait savoir
qu'à août avec bénédicte match
que j'aime bien titre personnel j'aime
bien juste que joueur après je sais pas
exactement comment ça pourrait fêter
avec portes en mai mais j'aime bien le
gemmeur profil
meiway c# et dispos sharks et après
du rnd cnds le potentiel
at il trop de personnages que je
partirai sur dyson d'agnès est ce que j
avais toujours je valorise beaucoup de
cui basket mais aussi que ce garçon donc
après c'est en fonction des goûts et des
couleurs évidemment on va parler un
petit peu des deux autres piques que
vous avez quand même entre entier ses 57
est ce qu'il ya un projet une ligne
directrice qui est un petit peu été
évoqués ou pas du tout est ce que à
titre personnel tu veux garder les deux
envie rien c'est quoi le projet
honnêtement ça s'est passé un procédé à
ces pics là je pense qu'ils peuvent être
très rapidement transféré à également
[Musique]
dans le temps d'un des vins des trade
je pense qu'on a besoin c'est aussi un
endroit draft et je pense que ben on a
parlé un peu avec jal engine du fait que
son profil existait pas important donc
serrée 1 un pivot riner ces genres
détruite le ça fait longtemps en plus
quand on n'a pas vraiment et se profile
donc si jamais il y avait ce type de
profil
disponible en 36 je pense que je pense
que ça serait une bonne idée
c'est tout ce que je peux voir pour
l'instant pour ces cliques la
façon on s'est souvent ces maisons qui
sont trop deuxième tour c'est souvent
des spécialistes quand même ils ont une
qualité au moins vite
est-ce que
qui est ce que vous avez à proposer dans
le profil de rim runner pour toi il ya
plus à vos yeux n'a pas mal ça tombe
bien je devrais me runner à partir de 35
36 s'il peut y avoir manu c'est vraiment
toi tu irais sortie
on est trop basiques sur ma mort comme
il s'agit de renault qui deviennent
instantanément c'est mark williams du
duc où se mêlent kamagaté du paris
basket ball et christian koloko
d'arizona
c'est trois ris bronner mais au profil
qui sont aussi différents
sachant que marc guillaume c'est quand
même annoncé comme un peu plus haut en
fin d'année dernière marquant trois
essais par gorgui précédente entre 20 et
45 c'est selon aussi les jeunes adorent
voir coq à
l'âne est ce que tu as d'autres noms
nous proposer
bon ça diabaté
ce garçon n'avait pas l'amour qui a été
fait sinon jenni williams d'arkansas et
white shark island ou bien si tu veux
ton bac tu t'es pas cap' niveau des
choses comme ça c'est là que j'ai draf
là tu trouves robert williams daniel
ghafour et michelle robinson donc
s'il vous faut tenter tu rates tu rates
mais un stand compte
et lucent a deux options soit tu prends
un spécialiste spécialistes genre nous
tirons un truc comme ça ou alors tu as
un freshman qui est tombée comme pitch
box candidat queyranne et je prends
ça peut être mais ou alors tu saches
troisième option
ce qui n est pas forcément beaucoup de
profits cette année un sursaut du stage
ont un problème j'ai l'impression
spagnolo cadets fadoq
khalifa diop way
procida il sera parti avant sans doute
renzo sa tête un responsable qui peut
être aussi tous les
laissez une nature est un joueur
intérieur s'est jamais président et
donc
voilà or voilà ce que tu as d'autres
questions profites-en dans chat aussi si
vous avez des questions sur soi il
confie qu on a évoqué n'hésitez pas
c'est un peu le moment après on va
fermer boutique ça fait une heure
quarante qu'on est ensemble je vois à
l'année ces petits dieux
on va l'essayer aller dormir se laisser
aller dormir et qui on sait très bien
qu'il est sorti blessé
ni argent tu veux bien attacher america
ce qui l'attend
roma c'est bon pour torres pour moi
c'était super intéressant
merci à toi pour la participation menus
halal merci beaucoup pour l'analyse
toujours en fines et le verbe bien senti
les autres n'ayez pas peur si vous êtes
encore là demain au pass ou qu'ils
il y aura sinon de sault presse il y
aura une et sa grosse voix et forcément
il y aura le boss himself
alex qui vous présentera tout ça donc
demain si vous voulez vous intéresser
aux pics 4 des kings qui peut être
encore une fois de master class
c'est demain et pourtant je les aime
beaucoup j'ai déjà j'adore les fans des
kings parce que je trouve qu'ils ont une
patience assez incroyable donc coeur sur
vous et gars merci beaucoup à tout
moment des curieux j'ai aussi une pensée
à
ceux antérieurs que vous voyez pas mais
qui bosse très dur je pense à julien je
pense à yacine je pense à maxime et il y
en a beaucoup d'autres que vous voyez
pas mais qu'il bosse très dur et puis
antoine et puis voilà je vous dis à très
vite des bisous à tous bailly